en un elevador se encuentra el bloque a
con masa m que está arriba del bloque b
con masa 2 m el elevador está bajando y
está disminuyendo su velocidad aquí
están estas masas en el elevador y al
estar disminuyendo la velocidad del
elevador en realidad se está acelerando
hacia arriba la magnitud de la fuerza
gravitacional de la tierra sobre el
bloque a sf sub jesús a la magnitud de
la fuerza ejercida sobre el bloque a por
el bloque b sf suba y la magnitud de la
fuerza ejercida sobre el bloque b por el
bloque
efe supe cómo se comparan las magnitudes
de las fuerzas fascinante pausa en el
vídeo y traten de reflexionar en cuál es
la respuesta correcta bueno vamos a
dibujar un diagrama de cuerpo libre del
bloque
aquí está el bloque a y hay un par de
cosas que sabemos primero que todo este
sistema se mueve hacia abajo y está
disminuyendo su velocidad así como que
el bloque está arriba del bloque b y
ambos están en el elevador y si esto se
mueve hacia abajo y está disminuyendo su
velocidad quiere decir que la dirección
la aceleración neta va hacia arriba esto
nos dice que la fuerza neta sobre el
bloque
va hacia arriba y si la fuerza neta va
hacia arriba quiere decir que la
magnitud de las fuerzas que actúan hacia
arriba es mayor que la magnitud de las
fuerzas que actúan hacia abajo para el
bloque
cuáles son las fuerzas que actúan hacia
abajo pues la fuerza de gravedad está
actuando sobre el bloque a con magnitud
efe sub jesús a y cuál es la fuerza en
el bloque a que actúa hacia arriba en el
enunciado nos dicen que la magnitud de
la fuerza ejercida sobre el bloque a por
el bloque b es f sub a por el hecho de
que el sistema esté disminuyendo su
velocidad hacia abajo nos damos cuenta
de que hay una aceleración neta hacia
arriba esto nos dice que la magnitud de
f suba a es mayor que la magnitud de la
fuerza de gravedad con esta información
ya podemos descartar algunas de las
opciones pero en todas las opciones
también se compara f sub así que cómo
podemos involucrar a efe sube en esta
desigualdad la clave aquí es la tercera
ley de newton ya que cualquiera que sea
la fuerza
ejerce sobre a recordemos que su
magnitud es eje sub ha debido a la
tercera ley de newton a va a ejercer la
misma fuerza sobre esta flecha apunta
hacia abajo pero tiene la misma magnitud
es f sub la magnitud de ambas fuerzas
es la misma otra forma de pensar en esto
es que efe s/a
es igual a efe sube debido a la tercera
ley de newton y como sabemos que todo el
sistema acelera hacia arriba porque se
mueve hacia abajo pero está disminuyendo
su velocidad sabemos que todo esto es
mayor que la fuerza de gravedad sobre el
bloque a esto coincide con la opción b y
con esto terminamos